how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it is officially one month until
Avengers end game hits theaters and with
only one month until the movie comes out
we just got some new promotional posters
from Marvel for the movie with a new
tagline avenge the Fallen each
individual actor took to social media
this morning and posted these themselves
so it was quite a treat this morning but
the most interesting thing about these
posters are that they show the dead
Avengers the posters for all of the
heroes that are still alive art in full
color but the posters from the fallen
are in black and white this is something
that Marvel has been doing with their
trailers every time they show the dead
Avengers they put them in black and
white it obviously seems like they're
sticking with that until Avengers end
game comes out with these posters do
come a couple of reveals for one we see
Valkyrie this is the first time that
Marvel has officially told us that
Valkyrie will be in Avengers in game yes
we've had toy leaks but nothing came
officially from Marvel and now we have
this new poster for her and she's in
full color which means she is definitely
alive we also have one for happy Hogan
which means he's alive and will most
likely have a decent role in Avengers in
game and we finally see Loki Loki wasn't
a victim to the snap
Thanos snapped his neck and he's the
same as Valkyrie this is the first time
that Marvel has mentioned Loki being in
Avengers in game yes we all assume that
he's going to be in endgame but this is
the first time that Marvel has mentioned
him so it'll be interesting to see how
he makes his return we also have Wong
but it has been confirmed that he'll be
an in-game before we got these posters
but he'll most likely have a bigger role
in endgame than he did in Avengers
infinity war perhaps communicating with
Doctor Strange who could be in the soul
world there's a poster for Pepper Potts
in full-color which proves that she's
alive most of us already knew this
especially since we've seen her with her
rescue armor on and some leaked photos
but some people still doubted she was
alive saying that she could have been
dusted but this proves that she is alive
and then we have a poster for sheree and
it is in black and white so she is
officially dead yes we saw Bruce Banner
looking at the screen in the trailer
which showed her being dead but some
people thought that was misdirection but
her
poster being in black-and-white proves
that she was dusted nothing really
revealed here with Rockettes poster but
he does look super sad which makes
perfect sense he's the only remaining
member of the guardians of the galaxy
he basically lost his whole family
including Groot who we learned was
basically his son we found out from the
directors that as he was turning to dust
his last words I am Groot meant dad so
things are definitely getting more
exciting the closer we get to Avengers
in game a few reveals today by these
posters and hopefully we'll get a little
bit more information before Avengers and
game comes out but let me know what you
think about these new posters which
one's your favorite and how excited are
you for Avengers in game to come out in
just one month let me know in the
comments down below and a reminder about
my giveaway I'm giving away five IMAX
tickets right now so you and some
friends can go see Avengers in game at
IMAX if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]